Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: John Ockey
Buongiorno.
Questi 18 minuti, per riuscire a parlare
di uno Stato senza prigioni
sono veramente pochi.
Mi sento quasi, un po',
imprigionato nel tempo,
perché è un tema che richiederebbe
una riflessione profonda
e soprattutto molto, molto,
molto prolungata.
Io credo che si debba partire, comunque,
dal cercare a riuscire
a dare un senso, un significato,
a identificare bene questa parola,
che cos'è un carcere.
Che cos'è un carcere?
Perché se vogliamo riflettere
un po' sulla possibilità
di vedere una comunità
nella quale non esiste un carcere
per prima cosa dobbiamo riuscire
a capire bene che cos'è un carcere.
Già la parola stessa,
che deriva dal latino,
dà l'idea delle sbarre.
Il carcere, quindi, è caratterizzato,
in primo luogo, dalle sbarre.
In Italia, in carcere,
le persone stanno chiuse in celle
che hanno mediamente la dimensione
di un po' meno di 12 metri quadri.
Non uno soltanto in 12 metri quadri,
ma più persone in 12 metri quadri.
In periodi di crisi,
cioè quando c'è sovraffollamento,
le persone sono, magari, sei, sette, otto,
in meno di 12 metri quadri
nei quali esistono
anche le brandine a castello
e tutto quello che può servire
alle persone che ci abitano,
compreso una specie di bugigattolo
in cui c'è o una turca o un water
e un lavandino, nel quale
si fa anche da mangiare.
Le persone, in questo carcere,
stanno normalmente -
ci sono delle eccezioni, ma sono rare -
per 22 ore al giorno.
Se togliamo le ore d'aria,
per tutto il resto [del tempo]
stanno nella cella chiusa a chiave,
insieme ad altre tre, quattro,
cinque, sei persone.
E chi sta dentro a queste celle
può vedere i propri familiari
soltanto per complessive sei ore al mese.
Questo è il carcere in Italia.
Gabbie, persone chiuse,
per un tempo così definito,
nelle condizioni che vi dicevo.
Ecco, allora, se questo è un carcere,
beh, esistono delle condizioni
in cui una persona può subire
una limitazione della libertà personale
in modo completamente diverso.
Adesso forse non ci sono quasi più,
ma quando andavo io alle medie, al liceo -
io per fortuna mia non ci sono mai stato -
c'erano i collegi,
e i ragazzi che vivevano in un collegio
potevano circolare
soltanto nell'ambito del collegio.
Poi tornavano, magari, a casa
il sabato e la domenica,
però durante la settimana
erano anche loro limitati
nella possibilità di muoversi
oltre una determinata struttura.
Il collegio non è un carcere,
per intenderci.
Allora quando io mi riferisco,
immagino uno stato senza carcere
non escludo che possa esistere
la possibilità di tenere delle persone -
quando le persone sono pericolose,
ed esclusivamente quando
le persone sono pericolose -
in un posto in cui hanno dei confini.
Ma questo non è più un carcere
nel momento in cui questa situazione
non è una situazione
nella quale le persone
vivono in una limitazione
come quella che vi dicevo prima.
Non è un carcere quando le persone
possono, per esempio,
liberamente muoversi
nell'ambito di quella struttura,
uscendo dalla cella,
uscendo dalla camera,
perché non è più una cella,
e potendo passeggiare
in quell'ambito e così via.
Nel carcere, normalmente non si lavora.
Credo che sia l'87%, più o meno,
dei detenuti che in Italia non lavorano:
passano, infatti, la grandissima
parte della giornata
chiusi nelle loro celle, 22 ore al giorno.
A che cosa serve il carcere?
A che cosa dovrebbe servire,
il carcere, per tutti noi?
Io credo che il collegamento
primo, immediato, diretto
sia con la sicurezza.
Il carcere serve a dare sicurezza
alle persone che sono fuori.
Perché serve a dare sicurezza?
Non perché le persone
che hanno commesso qualche cosa
di dannoso nei confronti degli altri,
che hanno commesso un reato, un crimine,
ci restano per tutta la vita.
Perché sarebbe assurdo
anche soltanto pensare
che chi ha commesso un reato,
un furto, per esempio,
debba passare tutta la vita in carcere.
Sarebbe addirittura criminogeno questo,
perché se tutte le persone
che hanno commesso un reato
dovessero passare la loro vita in carcere,
allora non ci sarebbero differenze:
il furto equivarrebbe all'omicidio.
In carcere ci si sta
per un tempo limitato, generalmente.
Purtroppo, in Italia, io dico purtroppo,
esiste ancora l'ergastolo;
[ma] salvo i casi di ergastolo,
ci si sta per un tempo limitato.
Per quel tempo limitato
la sicurezza è garantita,
nei confronti di quella singola persona,
dal fatto che questa persona è esclusa
dai rapporti con tutte le altre persone.
Però questo vale per un tempo limitato.
La sicurezza dipende,
si dice, da che cosa?
Dalla capacità di deterrenza
che il carcere svolge
nei confronti della persona
che viene incarcerata
e di tutti gli altri, che vedono
che se qualcuno commette un reato
viene messo in prigione.
Ecco, io credo che questa sia
una convinzione completamente sbagliata.
In effetti, il carcere non serve
a svolgere una attività di deterrenza
e quindi a prevenire
comportamenti devianti,
comportamenti che possono
danneggiare gli altri.
Perché ve lo dico?
Perché ci sono i numeri
a testimoniarlo, a dimostrarlo.
Il 69% delle persone
che escono oggi dal carcere
commettono nuovi reati.
Vuol dire che lo strumento
è uno strumento che non va bene,
che non serve ad aumentare
la nostra sicurezza.
Pensate, ci sono degli strumenti diversi
che invece garantiscono
in misura notevolmente maggiore.
Però lasciamo perdere per il momento:
ci arriveremo forse,
perché io ho davanti un cronometro,
voi non lo vedete.
Mancano dieci minuti
e 39, 38, 37, 36 secondi.
Vediamo se riusciremo ad arrivarci,
e seguiamo il filo.
Il 69% delle persone che esce dal carcere
commette nuovi reati.
Il che vuol dire che, evidentemente,
il carcere non ha un'efficacia deterrente,
nemmeno nei confronti
delle persone che ci sono state.
Figurarsi nei confronti degli altri,
che non hanno nemmeno provato
questa incredibile privazione
della libertà personale.
La quale, così "en passant",
potremmo chiederci:
è in coerenza con la nostra Costituzione?
Quello che vi ho descritto
prima del carcere
è in coerenza con l'art. 27
della Costituzione,
che dice che "la pena deve tendere
alla rieducazione del condannato,
e non può consistere in trattamenti
contrari al senso di umanità"?
Io vi pregherei di provare a immaginarvi -
ciascuno di noi si immagini,
per conto suo,
di rimanere, giustamente
o ingiustamente non importa,
provare a immaginarsi
che cosa si sentirebbe
se si fosse messi in quella condizione.
Ma non per tanto, facciamo sei mesi.
Ciascuno di noi provi a sentire,
simulando ovviamente,
le proprie sensazioni
dopo aver passato sei mesi,
insieme ad altre quattro,
cinque, sei persone
in 12 metri quadri,
con il bugigattolo di fianco,
potendo incontrare, vedere
per sei ore al mese tutti i suoi parenti.
Uscirebbe riconciliato
con il resto della società,
o non gli verrebbe voglia
di fargliela pagare?
Il carcere è un luogo di riconciliazione,
o è un luogo nel quale si coltiva
questo desiderio di rivincita,
questa sensazione di essere stati oppressi
e di voler riprendersi
danneggiando gli altri?
Allora, fatta questa premessa,
ma è possibile qualche cosa di diverso?
Qualche cosa di diverso esiste.
Ci sono dei paesi,
per esempio la Norvegia,
in cui ci sono delle carceri
che secondo il nostro metro
non dovrebbero neanche chiamarsi carceri.
Perché si trattano di appartamenti,
nei quali le persone
possono entrare e uscire,
avendo soltanto il limite
del perimetro di quel luogo,
in cui stanno come starebbero
dei ragazzi che studiano in un collegio.
Ci sono, delle cose simili.
E chi è posto in quelle condizioni,
beh, non passa sdraiato
sul proprio letto la giornata:
no, o studia o lavora.
E cioè svolge un'attività
che è tesa al reinserimento della persona.
Io credo che il maggior problema
che riguarda chi si trova in carcere
sia proprio quello relativo
alla capacità di assumersi responsabilità,
e cioè di rispondere agli altri,
che vuol dire di stare insieme agli altri,
di rispettare le regole che ci siamo dati,
col contributo più o meno incisivo
di ciascuno di noi,
per vivere insieme
nel modo più dignitoso possibile.
Ma voi pensate
che una necessità del genere,
l'acquisizione della responsabilità,
possa essere soddisfatta
attraverso un regime
che impedisce il lavoro
e rende difficile lo studio?
E non c'è soltanto quello che vi dicevo.
Non esistono soltanto queste strutture:
esistono anche dei sistemi, dei mezzi
che in Italia sono, chi lo sa perché,
assolutamente sconosciuti.
Uno di questi è costituito
dalla giustizia riparativa,
e noi non sappiamo neanche
che cosa voglia dire la parola,
nonostante che in Europa
non soltanto se ne parli,
ma se ne pratichi
da una sessantina d'anni:
se mi ricordo bene, risale al 1964
l'inizio di questa sperimentazione
che poi è diventata normativa.
In Belgio, in Germania, in Austria:
ma non soltanto in Europa,
un po' in tutte le parti del mondo,
negli Stati Uniti, in Canada,
in Nuova Zelanda, in Australia.
Che cosa si fa?
In primo luogo,
si tiene conto delle vittime.
Vedete, il nostro sistema
la vittima la disconosce completamente,
è come se la vittima non esistesse.
Addirittura, per poter ottenere
il risarcimento del danno
la vittima deve prendersi un avvocato,
costituirsi in giudizio, partecipare;
se non prende lei l'iniziativa,
la vittima io credo che sia,
in qualche modo,
un pochino danneggiata dal sistema.
Pensate cosa succede a una ragazza
che abbia subito una violenza,
che deve andare a fare la denuncia
e raccontare tutto,
nei minimi particolari,
ai Carabinieri o alla Polizia.
E poi viene richiamata
dal Pubblico Ministero
e deve rivivere il dolore
di quello che ha subito un'altra volta.
E poi davanti al Giudice,
in contraddittorio con il difensore
di chi l'ha aggredita,
che farà di tutto per screditarla.
È questo quello che riserva
alla vittima il nostro sistema;
ma riserva qualche cosa
di molto meno drammatico,
ma perlomeno fastidioso,
anche a chi ha subito un furto.
Che deve andare a fare la denuncia,
e poi vai a processo,
perché ti chiamano per confermare che,
ammesso che sia stato trovato l'autore,
che è una cosa, per la verità, rarissima.
Ecco: invece, con il sistema
della giustizia riparativa,
si dà un grande rilievo alla vittima.
Perché la finalità di questo metodo
è quella di riuscire a riparare,
per quanto è possibile, la vittima;
e contemporaneamente,
rendere cosciente il responsabile
del male che ha fatto.
È un percorso attraverso il quale
la vittima, e il responsabile,
vengono portati ad incontrarsi
in modo che l'una possa recuperare
il senso della propria dignità,
che attraverso il reato è stato distrutto;
e l'altro, senza essere per questo
distrutto dai sensi di colpa,
possa rendersi conto
di quello che ha fatto
e per questo, perché se ne è reso conto,
evitare di farlo in futuro.
Ecco, dicevo, da noi è sconosciuto,
nonostante una decisione quadro
dell'Unione Europea
abbia reso sostanzialmente obbligatoria
l'introduzione del sistema
di giustizia riparativa
in tutti gli stati membri dell'Unione.
Noi siamo molto lontani
dal concepire una possibilità del genere.
Allora io credo
che faremo fatica ad arrivarci
fin tanto che la nostra cultura,
il nostro modo di pensare,
continuerà ad essere così tanto resistente
rispetto alla possibilità
di cambiare quella idea di fondo
secondo la quale il male
va retribuito col male.
Pensate che rischio abbiamo,
quello di confondere il male col bene.
Se noi pensiamo che il male
si supera, si recupera, si trasforma
infliggendo il male,
allora trasformiamo
il male che infliggiamo in bene,
perché è un male che serve a cancellare
il male commesso precedentemente.
Sarà ben male, per chi lo subisce,
essere messo in una cella
in quelle condizioni che vi dicevo, no?
Se noi pensiamo
che fare male ad una persona
serva per arrivare al bene,
allora non c'è più differenza
tra il bene e il male;
entriamo in una confusione assoluta,
e non abbiamo più punti di riferimento.
Io credo che sia necessario approfondire.
Mancano soltanto 31 secondi, anzi 30...
Credo che sia necessario entrarci dentro,
credo che sia necessario
che ciascuno di noi si ponga il problema.
Ma non per un senso di umanità,
che pure è importantissimo;
io direi anche per arrivare
a centrare quell'obiettivo,
quello di trovare un sistema
attraverso il quale
poter essere, ciascuno di noi,
più sicuro di quanto lo sia adesso.
(Applausi)